I've been doing this job for quite some
time now 60 years and I like to think
I'm a pretty good boss you absolutely
are okay well you really are thank you
Andy thank you and it's important to me
that everyone here on the crew because
we work with a big crew it's important
to me that they're happy and I'm always
looking for ways to improve things here
and make it a little better so this
morning I put out a complaint box
backstage just to kind of check it out
yeah blade box yeah there it is yeah
that way if anyone has a complaint they
can just fill out a card put it in the
box and I can maybe try and fix it and
all of these are from one day yeah yeah
wow that had SAT full not even a full
day I put this out like two hours ago
Wow
crammed full of them and it's it's
really a little troubling let's check
out the some of the issues are yeah okay
well this is interesting
it says here first card we need a better
nut spoon nuts not sure what a nut spoon
is that's weird
okay let's check out this one right here
the nut spoon situation is unacceptable
what what is it nuts I don't know it's
as crazy
two words nut spoon oh my god can
someone please tell me what a nut spoon
is hey hey Conan I might be able to
clear this up okay
this is this is great this is Tony our
camera guy Tony yeah tell me tell us
what is a nut spoon
okay Conan to put it simply the nut
spoon is the bane of the entire crews
existence okay that seems a little
extreme Andy I know it's extreme but you
want to let's hear about it we will work
rhyme will hear about come on okay so
here's the deal with the nut spoon
there's a snack table backstage right
that's where the crew gets their snacks
yeah yeah that makes sense sure yeah and
one of the things on the snack table is
a small paper plate with some nuts on it
sometimes it's almonds sometimes it's
cashews sometimes it's pistachios
sometimes it's honey roasted peanuts
sometimes it's a mix of different kinds
of nuts or what we on the crew call a
nut mix okay you know what we get it
just tell me about the nut spoon okay
okay so when the crew wants some nuts to
snack on we don't just grab them with
our hands because that could spread
germs right instead we use a spoon to
scoop up the nuts and then we transfer
the nuts from the spoon to our other
hand it's just good hygiene and do you
know what we call this spoon Conan then
that spoon bingo you get a gold star
okay now here's where the story
maintains the same level of
interestingness the spoon in question ie
the nut spoon it's a small plastic tea
spoon like this one okay Tony why do you
have a plastic tea spoon on you I don't
know Andy why are you a dick I'm just
asking questions
[Applause]
now as you can see the spoons very small
and the bowl of the spoon is very
shallow okay so when you try to scoop up
nuts from the plate you end up nudging
more nuts off the plate then you
actually pick up with the spoon it's
almost impossible to eat nuts here at
the Conan show Conan okay I'm sorry Tony
is it really that hard to pick up nuts
with that spoon hey Robby why don't you
tell Conan what you told me this morning
I've never successfully eaten any nuts
here at work pretty sad right yeah I
mean this one time I got one nut on the
spoon but then when I was trying to like
transfer that nut from the spoon to my
other hand
I dropped the nut I feel you're Robby
yeah since then man I'm done like that's
I just stopped trying to eat nuts here
at work I don't blame you I still eat
nuts at home though
yeah okay guys guys I had no idea the
nut spoon situation was going on I
really did hey everybody come on John's
going for the record
hey that's our prop master pill tall
what record are you talking about bill
the nut spoon record come on you don't
want to miss this okay I guess this is
pretty exciting which is here all the
commotion is about Billy can I get a
shot of what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
back to you going Wow Tony you really
opened my eyes the whole nut spoon
situation now here's the idea what if I
replace the nut spoon with this white
plastic soup spoon okay yeah I don't I
don't see how that solves the problem
except well it is slightly larger and a
little deeper than the current nut spoon
oh thanks Conan we're gonna eat so many
nuts at the crew Oscar party okay that's
great Oscar's were Sunday Joey
[Applause]
take it easy oh hell the nuts bone
everyone
you
you